- I don't like them.
(funny tuba music)
(hinge squeaking)
- My name is Oona, and
I'm seven years old.
- Blake.
Blaire.
- Isabella, and I'm nine years old.
- I'm--
- Five in June.
- Mommy is chirty-five.
- I have a lot of pets.
I have calerpittars that are chrysalis.
- I want a dog.
- Sloths.
They're really cute, and
they take their time.
- I also have a very tiny toad,
and a cat, and a fish, and a bird.
It's a bad combination.
- No!
- I like pigs a lot.
- I would like a pig.
- They oink too much.
- They oink too much!
- I like piglets!
(murmuring)
(gasps)
(pig oinks)
- No!
- Oh, my gosh!
- [Woman] Oh, my god!
- They're brown?
(pig oinks)
- [Woman] You can play with it, Isabella!
Don't be afraid!
- I don't wanna hold one.
- I feel like they would be heavy.
(pig oinks)
I like how they snort.
It's cute.
- Pig!
- No! (whimpers)
- I have chocolate!
I have chocolate!
(cries)
Look!
- [Woman] Do you want
me to give it to Mommy?
- Your mouth is so tiny-feeling!
(pig oinks)
(gasps)
(pigs oink)
- I think my cat would get upset at them.
- Pig!
Pig!
Look!
- Say hi!
(pig oinks)
- Hi!
- [Woman] She's talking to you!
- I've never been so surprised before!
- How did they even know I wanted a pig?
- It was the best surprise.
- I don't think they would
wanna be with my cat.
She's just so feisty,
and she's in love with my dad's deodorant!
- I want a toy now.
(laughter)
- You want a toy?
- So I tell 'em, "Don't come
to my house with deodorant on!"
(gentle, upbeat music)
(quick whoosh)
(hinge squeaking)